[Music]
little disclaimer for parents uh whose
kids might be listening i'm talking to
you emilia and bodhi uh there's gonna be
a little bit of drug talk taking drugs
and the effects that drugs have on
certain people you love a good
disclaimer yeah i sure do well i think
it's helpful and i think it's respectful
out of respect to the kids so we got
really stoned once
we were really stoned christian and i
were on a trip we were driving up the
eastern seaboard
and um i think we were in north carolina
doesn't matter where we were we were in
a small southern town and at a hotel we
were desperate for some snacks and we
didn't come prepared no and we weren't
responsible stoners and we the vending
machine they had there was the least
stonery options it was like the worst
yeah it was like doublemint gum yeah
like a lot of like savers a lot of water
options like no good stoner treats yeah
um like banana chips
um
and so we went to the front desk and we
asked like desperate where is there a
place to eat is there anything any food
options in the area late at night so so
he was like no man nothing's open sorry
yeah and of course we didn't want to
drive too far and um because we were
stones
we're stoned and stuck stuck and he said
you know we were like ah it's too bad
and we were
kind of hemming and hawing in the lobby
just like not knowing what to do we were
we couldn't go back up to our room
without food and and almost as an
afterthought the guy behind the counter
he said well i mean all we really have
here are these
fresh baked
chocolate chip cookies and he like he
gestured over and there were
individually
wrapped
thick big
warm like steamed delicately rising from
the case and we were like
huh we i i would love to have witnessed
our reaction from his point of view it
was a happy ending yeah it was and um
here's a happy beginning life could be a
dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
listening to life is short i am your now
satisfied host justin long life could be
a dream
[Music]
and with me as always as he was that
night that desperate night christian
long brother hi it was it was funny
because we got i mean it was obviously
we were elated to get these cookies and
and he we were i was close to crying and
and
we got him back to the room and you can
tell the gross part of the story now it
was when we got really like desperate
for
milk yeah yeah i don't know if you had
even eaten yours yet i think i tore into
mine it hits you right away when you
have a warm
chocolate they're big they're like the
size of a pancake
they're like meaty and like soft and
immediately you want milk got milk i
mean what is the lesson there it's like
he never really satisfied i mean but we
would have been satisfied if we had had
a nice cold glass and it would have been
more satisfied there was satisfaction
but it was incomplete the gross part is
we contaminate oh yeah i know we
contemplated because we were so
desperate is that desperate for milk
we're so desperate for milk products we
thought about
drinking
the little
creamers
from the coffee stand little little half
and half creamers did you i don't think
they were coffee mates i think they were
just half and half yeah but we thought
about sipping on those with the cookies
but but i'm very very relieved to say we
didn't do it yeah we um were
i mean
i i remember i was talking about like
what would you do for a glass of milk
like what are they it was like one of
those commercials yes it would have been
a great milk commercial
why are we talking i was going to ask
you oh i'm asking you why
but but i could feel this one why are we
talking about really want being stoned
and really wanting a food item that you
can't have it reminds me
of a movie that i saw years ago oh pray
tell i would say a couple decades ago at
this point oh my god harold and kumar go
to white castle yes and
it stars front of the show neil patrick
harris
has a very pivotal role in it most
importantly right now it's star's
current friend of the show
cal pen cal pen ladies and gentlemen
kumar yes and many more things star of
the night he's great actor who's in the
namesake and uh stan wilder uh
back in the day and um you also might
know that cal worked for a while in the
white house and the obama under the
obama administration he is um a
political figure he went from being a an
activist a you know an actor who used
his platform talk about talking walking
the walk
not talking he talked the talk for a
while um so we we talk about all of that
now he is an author of a very very
entertaining book about his life called
you can't be serious which is a very
appropriate title because you know i
think a lot of people thought of cal
throughout his life he talks about this
in the book as someone who
can't be
serious do you think that's why he
called it that should have asked him
well maybe i did i've heard of you yeah
we'll see
um but we do talk about we catch up i
hadn't seen him in a while how do you
know him oh right good good context um
cal that's what i'm here for and i met
what we had met in passing as actors do
over the years because it's a small
world but um then our world became
smaller when we started both doing
surrogate stuff for the obama the first
obama campaign uh that we were
both compelled to do thanks to friend of
the show olivia wilde but then you never
got a job in the white house no i was
never asked um in fact they suggested
that perhaps i stay away what position
do you think you could have had oh
that's a good question um
i could have been you know i this is
gonna sound crazy but i think the only
job i really could have done is um like
tour guide of the white house like a
white house tour guide or a secret
service maybe
well only because i
you know i don't i don't know enough i'm
not well versed enough to do anything
truly political maybe you could have
wrangled frogs on the property yeah or i
could have done landscaping stuff on the
property um but not the landscaping
there requires a lot of strength no
no but i do like to mow lawns and i like
to prune
i could have done that um but what cal
did was a little bit more involved he
was well he talks about it let's get
into it
it's um he's such an interesting guy and
such a smart person
and uh somebody i've always just been so
fond of and so i was happy to catch up
with him and i hope you're happy to
get to hear this ketchup here he is
uh
harold and kumar's and the white house's
cow pen
life could be a dream
[Music]
you look cool
thank you i have
i haven't i haven't really been home
because i've been on this book tour so
there's yeah it's just boxes and boxes
behind me well now i want to see that
it's all um i'll show you
there's a cal showing me his um yeah
just it just looks like a really spoiled
kid just had christmas i know so it's a
combination of like oh i opened this box
which has my own books in it because
those are the promo copies that i need
to bring with me to the next city
and
here are the dirty jeans that i couldn't
drop off at the cleaners i remember
working with hal linden an amazing act i
mean a legend um
with bart he was starting barney miller
we did a play together not too long ago
and he he gave as a rap gift or as like
an opening night present he gave out his
album and signed it uh and i thought why
not
it's personal it's something he created
but my reaction to it initially was like
that's a little arrogant to presume that
somebody would want your thing but then
i think especially with your book i've
known you for years and it was such a
great way to get to know you to know you
better you know thank you
truly it i loved i loved diving into
cal's like young cal and like knowing
what
knowing more about you those are those
are things that we've never really had
occasion to talk about and you do it so
eloquently
thank you i mean that's the thing isn't
it about about stuff like this is like
you
you're friends with somebody you've
known them for years especially by the
way for you and i at different points in
our careers right like i think we first
met when we were like in our 20s totally
having had the chance to have done these
like crazy comp you know r-rated
comedies in like the 2000s were a very
different beast than they are than they
are today and then and then you know
suddenly going from that to like oh i'm
playing a dad or like my job as a doctor
i have i have a mature job because i'm
older now those are the characters i'm
playing i know i'm playing a boss i'm
playing like the annoying older boss in
a thing this weekend um in toronto i
want to talk to you about speaking of
toronto uh that it was just announced
you're you're gonna be producing and
starring and i can't i i'm so curious
about the super fan about nav
um who basketball fans would know as the
he's like the raucous raptors fan who is
always um he's a sikh right he wears a
turban he's always he's unmistakable at
the games incredible guy i remember the
first time i saw him when we shot
designated survivor in toronto we'd get
a random last minute tickets to the game
they're always up in the stands and i'm
like who is the seek man
down on like courtside
seeking attention talking right yes
talking trash
oh like
wild he's getting up
incredible like just i mean on one level
just awesome if you're a sports fan on
another level you know you don't see
people who look like you very much on tv
growing up and certainly yeah sports
world and i was like this dude is
awesome and being so like brazen being
so like
you know it's like drake he's like the
sikh drake i mean they're friends
they're friends oh they must be yeah
yeah uh his story is very very cool he
escaped religious persecution against
sikhs in india in
the 80s uh 80s or early 90s ended up in
in canada and couldn't find a job in
canada because of his uh religion and
his ethnic background um worked his ass
off in a car dealership and ended up
working his way up so many people quit
when he joined that that car dealership
oh my god and it's a it's a wild story
because obviously toronto now is just
known for its diversity it's sort of
people joke that it's like the it's like
a swiss version of new york
which i think just means cleaner um yes
yes cleaner and safer yeah but he so his
he goes from that to like you know he's
never missed a raptors game since 1995.
what
yeah no home game sorry home game oh
my god yeah does he go to away games i
know he goes
and then he got inaugurated into the
into the nba hall of fame he's the only
non-player
to uh
be in the hall of fame so it's just such
a what a wild story story yeah yeah well
you so you'll be playing him you'll be
playing we're playing him i'm ep his uh
his film it's a team of us so um we
announced the partnership and then now
we actually have to go off and you know
hire a writer and a director and put the
oh my god and and cal not to dwell on
this too long but now just to put it
back he's a wildly successful in what
what what exactly does he do now that
what he brought he bought out he bought
out these car dealerships like oh oh wow
he went from literally barely getting a
job selling cars unbelievable
climbing his way up and i think he owns
several of them now it's uh i forget the
exact accolade but it's something like
like the number one car dealership in
all of canada or something like that
like
which he attributes to his his work
ethic i guess which is true is just you
know he definitely has passion well you
must have been that story a story like
that must resonate with you because um
you had a a version of the cards growing
up sorry yes yes you love to drive
i knew this about you that you grew up
in suburban new jersey and uh but you
are so you're second generation from in
your family's from india um those
stories are hilarious about the proms
you went to and i love how you detail
that one woman uh how she those
the kids singing that song how they
changed the lyrics to that song
um
yes yes yeah the the the girls were
saying they changed it to like hey [ __ ]
get like like let's [ __ ] or something
it's the interlude where it goes
[Music]
and then they would yell hey hey [ __ ]
get laid get [ __ ]
and we're in seventh grade yeah seventh
seventh grade and you your family is um
they seemed a lot more conservative in
that regard and like in in terms of
cursing and as was mine you know like
the thought of doing that publicly would
have been
i would have been grounded for
months if not a year that specific
specific story took place at a bar
mitzvah uh on on a boat like here i am
the the kid of the kid of immigrant
parents my dad moved to america twelve
dollars in his pocket uh worked his way
up enough for you know when my brother
and i were born and raised in new jersey
we lived in a in a suburb which kind of
sheltered us a little bit but we were
really close to new york city and what
did he do at the time cal my dad my dad
is an engineer so he yeah yeah he moved
here with 12 in his pocket and the
opportunity to go to grad school for
engineering which is a big if and it's
we often forget about this when we talk
about things like immigration like
there's so much rhetoric about like well
if this group did it how come the other
group couldn't do it and the simple fact
is you know in the late 60s or mid 60s
rather there was a shortage of engineers
and doctors in america
and so immigration laws particularly
from asia changed to allow certain
groups of asian americans or certain
groups of asians to become americans to
fill these labor shortages that's the
biggest reason you see so many brown and
yellow doctors and engineers oh
interesting it's not because of any uh
thing inherently just genetic
genetically much better but more
predisposed to it right i wish that was
the case it'd be a good it would be a
good nice thing now stereotype my
parents were this interesting mix of
like you know they were socially
conservative but also we were you know
40 minutes outside of new york city and
my dad would go into manhattan every day
for work so it's not like we were
sheltered from things but they
absolutely did not think that their
children's friends at school would be
saying hey hey [ __ ] get laid get [ __ ]
in a bar mitzvah um and so i just
remember watching these girls singing
this and realizing like okay so and this
is why i detailed it this way in the
book for that reason is like it's such a
vivid memory they they went to the dj
booth and requested a song and we knew
something was up based on their giggles
right there's a yeah yeah
it's a telltale giggle
yeah yeah and then the song comes on
they sing that interlude or shout it and
uh the the mom the the the bat mitzvah
girl's mom i remember her like very
fancy like she was drinking chardonnay
really long nails like that you'd see
unlike the housewives of new jersey
sort of that environment uh and all she
does is she leans over the banister of
you know them on this boat and she leans
down where the dance floor is and she
just yells nice language ladies very
nice language and she walks off and her
friends refill her wine glass and i
remember thinking are you kidding me if
this were like if this were like john v
javari sweet 16 all the aunties and
uncles would drown themselves in the
hudson river out of shame if someone was
saying words like that yeah i would be
outraged oh man wow i envied her i
witnessed behavior like that at the time
and i remember thinking
oh they're cool you know why can't my
parents be cool like that and you know
in retrospect through a different lens
through i think a a wiser lens uh
knowing more about the world and
people's behavior i'm really grateful
they disciplined me but you see what the
result of that is probably that girl is
probably now similar to her whatever
that gets passed on i've talked about
this with my i think it was my high
school acting teacher who i also talked
about uh in the book
and my parents
where it's like you know as an actor i'm
almost glad they didn't allow that kind
of language and i'm glad that they
always asked us to find words
to be descriptive about what we actually
were trying to say because being that
kind of articulate as an artist is
really helpful you know instead of just
screaming and ranting about something
without being able to express your
feelings totally yeah and i know we've
both done movies with a lot of improv
and heavy on improv and you are one of
you you're obviously very bright but you
also are quick you're quick-witted and
so i think to have access to language um
is important in that regard too but i
read a great article i'd recommend to
you called in the atlantic david brooks
article where he talks about other
countries i'm sure india i'm sure
pashtun and the languages that you know
probably have these words words that we
don't have that describe very specific
emotions you know um like the japanese
have a lot like like the emotion of
feeling a certain type of melancholy
when it rains you know something very
specific like that um i'd love to know
more words like that so i'm not
constantly saying this is amazing or
hilarious or you know whatever it is
that i overuse there's a word that i've
been trying to find uh an english
translation for there's a big text
change with my with my cousins it's a
gujarati word
um that means it's a kitchen utensil
specifically used to pick up
um stainless steel pots
but a specific type of pot in a specific
type of stainless steel instrument there
are similar words in english but there's
not an exact word for the gujarati word
sansi
which is like
right but they're but tongs are such a
wide
right like a a pair of tongs could be
used for anything yes that was actually
the conversation on this tech chain with
the cousins it's like hey what's the
word for sony and someone's like tongs i
was like no no no because it's a type of
tongue yes oh it's a specific type of
tongue with specific use i just love
that about language i do too i do too
one of my i had an uber driver recently
who was a linguist he was a
language professor and i i was
fascinating talking to him about
specifically about the sound the r sound
that a lot of southeast asian countries
were not able to are not capable of
pronouncing or producing because they
they just weren't used to it in their
lineage and their language lineage if
you will allow me to tell an r-rated
joke please which which you really led
into with the linguistics here um and i
tell the story obviously it's in the
book but i read my own audiobook
specifically for stories like this so
there's a story that i tell about when
when we were kids there's uh my one of
my mom's friends her name is is pushpa
auntie p-u-s-h-p-a
uh everybody's in onto your uncle
whether they're related or by blood or
not oh really oh that's interesting
similar to big jewish families big
italian families uh you know just
aunties and uncles are not necessarily
blood related so she
when she would put so pushpanty would
come over and and she was very docile
very sweet woman very conservative um
her nickname that her her friends would
give her was uh pushy because she was
obviously not pushy
at all yeah and so pochianti
was how she was known except in the
gujarati language like you were talking
about ours
the there's a similar transference that
happens with s
sounds
sometimes an sh becomes an s so instead
of saying i'm going to take a shower
it's i'm going to take a sour aha
so pocianti's
[Music]
and some auntie would just yell kids
[ __ ] auntie's here come downstairs
and we would just die laughing
like they would wonder why we were
laughing yeah
uncles what is wrong yeah
yeah exactly what's wrong with [ __ ]
all of a sudden do you find [ __ ] funny
right
i love i mean i love i love language and
i love dialects yeah and for so many
videos i don't know you spoke to so many
uh well just too
my hindi is bad my i speak gujarati in
english but my uh i'm trying to learn as
much hindi as possible it's not it's not
very good no well this linguist this uh
linguist also told me that when you are
a child a child of um bilingual parents
they are often they're they're not
they're often not they're able to
understand uh the other language but
they're not often able to say it back
yeah yeah yeah without your experience
that he doesn't really speak gujarati
but uh can understand huh huh your
younger brother yeah i wonder like you
know not to make everything about being
an actor but
there's a certain lack of shame that and
self-awareness that i think we have
so i do for a living yeah so it's it's
something like oh you want to try
speaking this language i'm like oh i'll
give it a shot i'll probably butcher
everything offend 50 of all people but i
will have learned something out of the
experience yes there's a fearlessness
yeah yeah yeah so i think some of it
some of it might be that and then
someone might just be you know i'm three
years older so it's three extra years of
of being around grandparents and and
having taken an interest in language and
things like that
cal you talk about um how you were one
of only two it's really funny how you
say the other the other kid was um i i
forget i think he was i was he iranian
uh the other kid
he was persian that you grew up with and
you arrived and you looked nothing alike
and yet the parents the teachers were
always mistaken getting your names wrong
they're always confusing you for one
another having such a like it sounds
like a really homogenized
experience
in terms of the other student body uh
how then did you have the confidence and
um was it a teacher was it a certain
play how did you then have the
confidence that you're talking about
that actor confidence to go and and do a
play to try to try to act the thing
about about uh uh persian araz in uh i
think it was like third grade or
something was that so our town was
fairly fairly homogenous you're right i
mean most folks were were white but
there were it's it's new jersey so so
many families also speak other languages
at home right the polish kids speak
polish with their grandparents a bunch
of italian families the the jewish kids
are close with their grandparents um and
so that was kind of the common factor
there and that was honestly the like i
wasn't i don't remember uh
being offended uh that that teachers
would confuse me yeah
mostly because i had not grown to yet
understand this behavior that of course
we all know quite so well now which is
like all look the same syndrome yes or
like some people just have a real tough
time
getting past this
part even if you don't look anything
like the other person yes
but at the time i was like oh wait how
come my teachers aren't as smart as i
thought they were like you've got to be
really stupid to think that me and heraz
are the same person like that's the
third grade brain
is just melting down and
like how is my teacher so stupid yeah
well it is that right that you've both
been reduced to this this thing the uh
an element of your
appearance has been right now who you
are
that's got to be a very strange feeling
i can relate only in so far as i was the
short kid so i get i get confused with
the other short kid with peter fiatus it
was like you repeat but very different
and obviously has much different
implications yeah but it's still like
it's it's that realization that whatever
that it is you know these are the things
that your your child brain is like wait
what
it makes you self-conscious about
something that you didn't think to be
self-conscious about right sure totally
yeah but what was that cal that that um
that get that spark i mean was it
something specific that that uh or were
you always just kind of like
uh you strike me as a very funny kid but
um i talked to a lot of people on the
show who had who just had this inherent
need to perform and they were yeah you
know they were little
and and that i i would imagine you
didn't necessarily have that would be my
guess is that i
it's a combination of those two things i
think the the notion that like i had to
perform
for me comes later it comes in high
school and into college and that's what
made me decide to major in in theater
was this idea that like
could it be a hobby
well maybe but
the difference between somebody who
pursues pursues the arts uh full-time
and somebody who does it as a hobby is
like i'm envious of the person who can
do it as a hobby and still feel
fulfilled
yes yeah
you're insane first of all and you can't
do it in any other way you have to do
only that right like right that's the
only thing that's going to give you that
outlet
how did your parents feel about that cal
i mean how did your dad specifically
because he seems like a more traditional
engineer that must have been a confused
was that confusing for them it was it
was confusing for them and and the and i
don't mean to deflect the first part of
your question because there was there
was a time in eighth grade i did love
performing yeah this was the beginning
of that catalyst of of me saying hey
maybe i want to do this as a career i
was 14.
um i was the tin man in our school
production of the wiz
okay
and
uh and i will i'll tell you the longer
version of this will be in the in the
book in the audiobook but basically the
gist of it was as you might know being
in drama club in middle school is like
it's terrifying it's not what the cool
kids do you get made fun of and bullied
all the time yeah and back then by the
way it wasn't even called bullying it
was just called being in eighth grade no
of course i know
you know
we couldn't define it i know
there wasn't really what you're right
there wasn't really a word for it it was
just like how it was exactly and i'm so
glad that there are protections for kids
now because back then it's like oh you
got spit on and somebody said something
racist yeah welcome to middle school
yeah it's like well okay well you are in
theater it's like you invited it yeah
exactly it's like oh so that's it we
can't be better than this as a society
wonderful uh so i'm glad that's all a
lot of that has has changed it was i
think the line was always just physical
pain it was like if somebody calls you
physical harm
that would be
i think you could probably identify that
as bullying that you could define it a
little bit but but you're right those
with the words and the pushing into
lockers like that stuff yeah
and so we do we do three scenes from the
play uh for the whole school against
rural because the director says if you
if you don't do this you're not going to
be able to put the the play up so you
were like oh for the whole school you
have to do old school and that's
different like they have an assembly the
kids they're forced yes
so i remember the kids coming in and
some kid this kid gabe cohen
yelled with a terrible indian accent
knowing that we could all hear him
backstage he yelled something like i am
excited for the tin man and like i was
like first of all you sound [ __ ]
irish you idiot but second of all
i wanted to like the 14 year old rage is
like i would like to go throat open yeah
on the middle school bleachers yeah and
then you know this kid ross miner next
to him must have yelled like i'm excited
for dorothy nice to be nice titties
right so you get both you get both the
xenophobia and the the blatant massage
yes thanks for watching we're terrified
backstage
and we get out there and there's one
scene in particular the third scene we
did where everybody gets their what they
want from the wizard of oz from the whiz
and so the tin man gets his heart and
the line that i'm supposed to say
the the wiz puts puts the heart around
my neck i'm supposed to walk uh
over to the edge of the stage and in a
very sweet way say all you fine ladies
out there watch out and it's supposed to
be this like very sweet thing that's oh
the tin man is capable of love now
because he has a heart yeah instead
the whiz gives me the heart around my
neck i walk over the edge of the stage
and i say all you fine ladies out there
and then i did this massive pelvic
thrust for some reason
and i just said
watch out
and the crowd went [ __ ] wild yeah the
girls started screaming the guys who
were five minutes ago making fun of us
started applauding
they're like
they're like
wild
yes
i get on the late bus on the on the way
home and they all start all the soccer
players who have been bullying us
mercilessly they started applauding and
at first i thought that it was a
[ __ ] applause like i was waiting for
the spirit yeah for like the second part
yeah and then they genuinely had like a
million questions about what it was like
to do theater and no kidding
i i thought to myself first of all like
[ __ ] you
yeah yeah yeah sure
second of all i was like you know
this is wild that
in my adult words now i realize what
that was which was being fascinated by
the suspension of disbelief that we put
into their heads where they thought they
were going to see one thing for people
who they viewed in one particular way
and instead
comedy deconstructed all of what they
had in their heads and their hearts and
made them smile and laugh and root for
us and totally change their perception
of something and i thought that if
that's a thing that that's i mean i
recognize that's what i love about
movies that's why i laughed when i was
watching family matters right like as a
kid
so that was the first time i remember
thinking like wait a second there's a
magic to this that i'd love to do for my
life it's also interesting that the the
idea of kids making fun of things and
and adults because i think a lot of them
don't really grow making fun of things
or being afraid of things now you know
being like blatantly racist to things
they just don't understand yeah and and
and in that moment perhaps you you
became a lot more human to them and and
they they laughed and so there's nothing
more connective than laughter i think no
i think that's right
i recognized that at some level too
there it was around that same time that
i saw um miranaire
from early films it's called mississippi
masala yes from washington yeah great
that's right
and i remember going to see with my
parents and my cousin and it was the
first time i saw brown people who were
not either cartoon characters um or yes
yeah
stereotypical kind of reductionist
uh-huh you know heavily accented eating
monkey brains in a steven spielberg
movie like that kind of a thing yeah and
and to be fair like of course i watched
the simpsons of course i watched steven
spielberg movies yeah it was weird that
those were the only depictions
i'm watching this miranda movie and i'm
seeing families that look like mine that
are by the way i'm not saying they have
to be positive characters these
characters are incredibly flawed and
they have problems sarita's character
has sex with denzel like things that you
just that humanize in the entire group
of people and i was floored in the same
way that exactly what you're saying is
like your perception changes of
something
and that was a similar part of the magic
yeah that must have been really
revelatory for you cal to see that and
and
are you struggling at that point because
god the kids kids
know how cruel they can be at that age
but but you you just being different
looking different um
must have been such an easy target
would you how would you process that
when you came home to your
family who who i mean that's that that
was normal to to you you know you're
looking at those relatives of yours and
and and it's it's that thing that's been
weaponized against you that must be a
very unique experience that i i
obviously will never know yeah there's
you know i've been getting some feedback
from people who who have already
downloaded the the audiobook and they've
said i i heard you talking about um
about your experience with the south
asian community the indian american
community around that same time my story
is not just about the times that i felt
vulnerable it's the times where i
thought how do i
power yeah empowered or by the same
token like what's wrong with me am i
just crazy i tell these stories about
how you know the there were like [ __ ]
anti for example right so he was not a
fan
of me going into the theater
uh and and she and a lot of her friends
would say things like you know are you
not smart enough to go to medical school
how come you're going into theater i
remember even in college you know i was
a theater major at ucla i remember
thinking like hey you know what maybe
it'll be cool to be at a university of
this size and this caliber and maybe
i'll meet some people with a similar
upbringing from me and at orientation i
just signed up for the indian student
union uh email list
and i remember the woman on the other
end of this picnic table who's taking
all the sign ups she goes uh hey what's
your name where are you from and what
are you majoring in and so i told her my
name i said i'm from new jersey and i'm
a theater and film major and she laughs
and she goes that's so funny no
seriously uh what are you majoring in oh
my god and she looked at the kid behind
me just ignoring me and goes hey what's
your name where are you from what are
you majoring in and i was just like well
that's a weird thing to say they never
added me to their email list and around
campus for those for my college years i
remember distinctly hearing from them in
passing like hey that's the kid who was
who was a sellout that's a kid who
didn't major in what our parents wanted
us to major in there were these two kids
in in rieber hall in my dorm floor um
and i laugh about it now obviously
because it seems so it feels so silly
that i let it bother me but um there
were two indian kids they were both uh
pre-med uh there and they were dating
each other and they if any time i would
run into them they would say such a
stupid [ __ ] like we'd be in the elevator
and i'd have my my bag of books they'd
go where are you going and i said oh i'm
just gonna hit up the library for an
hour and they would say uh well why
aren't you just like a theater major
don't you not have any real classes
and it's like you know as an adult you
just think like oh [ __ ] off right right
yeah yeah you could process it you're 19
yeah put it all on the line to move
halfway around or all the way across the
country
for your dreams and it just so the
reason i bring up the the lack of
support from the indian american
community is that's a conversation that
that rarely happens like we rarely say
hey how do we incentivize more uh people
from a particular community to tell
their stories it can't just be that
hollywood needs to be better although
obviously that's a big part of it we
also have to look internally in our own
communities and be like hey guess what
maybe [ __ ] on d needs to be
[Music]
cerebral is an online mental health
service that offers prescription
medication counseling and therapy for
anxiety depression adhd insomnia and
more it's one of the few services that
provides prescription medication online
through a licensed provider and ships
medications straight to your door so you
can skip the pharmacy lines you'll get
unlimited messaging with your care team
with the cerebro mobile app it's like
having your own personal care team
wherever you are you can connect with
your counselor and therapist on your own
schedule and through your laptop or the
cerebro mobile app you'll get affordable
treatments that are one-third the price
of traditional therapy and treatment
options are available with or without
insurance even if you're at a network
they'll provide you with the necessary
paperwork so you can easily submit a
claim simone biles is their chief impact
officer and she's a huge advocate for
mental health you know this and that's
why she loves using cerebral and for
listeners of this program you can
receive 65
off your first month of medication
management and care counseling go to
cerebral.com
long for 65 off your first month that's
just a total of 30 dollars to get
started join cerebral today on their
mission to make quality mental health
care accessible and affordable for all
oh man this is the best thrive market
it's an online membership based market
and they are on a mission to make
healthy living easy and affordable for
everyone so they'll deliver whatever you
need so you can spend more time
on what matters you should check out
thrive market they do it for you they
carry all of your favorite clean brands
that don't
clean out your wallets but you're
probably saying to yourself but they
don't have ethically sourced sustainable
things
actually they do you can shop everything
from ethically sourced pantry essentials
to sustainable meat and seafood to
non-toxic cleaning and beauty products
with thrive market your membership means
more for families in need and our planet
you join they donate a membership to a
family in need plus it's carbon neutral
shipping i've bought quite a few things
on thrive i've bought um yeah i've been
cooking a lot so i'll buy a lot of uh
produce
maca powder i bought recently they kind
of have everything and i love how
ethically sourced everything is
that the sustainable meat is fantastic
if you didn't think a grocery store
could do that well it can at thrive
market go to thrivemarket.com
long and join today to get 40 off your
first order 40
and a free gift thrive market dot com
slash long
hello hello again
[Music]
here you are at ucla what was that
program like what how how then accepting
was the acting program of you and did
they have anything any weird did they
place limitations on the roles you could
play did you ever encounter that in
college because i my experience was so
you could kind of try anything i went to
a very experimental school where um
anything goes i loved i loved college i
i felt like the um most of i think my
personal growth in those years was
outside of the theater program so i mean
it wasn't as much of a pre-professional
program as maybe i was expecting and so
i tried to really take advantage of
things that were happening around los
angeles so try to get internships i did
a ton of extra work
where i just reasoned like you get paid
40 bucks so if you have a day off from
school or if you have a late class or
something yeah you get paid you know 40
bucks to basically you know to be an
extra be a background artist and you get
to see how a a professional film or tv
set operates and so i just thought like
i didn't have a car i was taking the bus
to places so i would have to like see
where this this extra work was happening
whether i could get there whether i
could borrow a friend's car um you know
i never knew anybody who was in
entertainment i didn't know how to get
my foot in the door and so those even
something as innocuous as that was like
exhilarating it just yeah i bad feeling
yeah it made me feel connected to
something i wanted to do to be on a film
set and like if you know i suppose with
because of the way they treat a lot of
extras um if you can get past that you
can do that and actually still want to
be on a film set and still be like as
intrigued about the industry
as you were before i imagine that's a
real litmus test you know
what was that experience like so i had
done i
had done like a couple of couple days of
extra work on sabrina the teenage witch
which was exciting because the cast was
basically my age yeah and then after
getting an agent one of the early
auditions i had was also first for a
speaking role in sabrina the teenage
witch and i was really pumped about this
it was for a guy they had written him
his name was prajeeb um but they the way
they was just a kid in sabrina's study
group i think there were like three
lines i'm gonna create a backstory where
like he is from the pacific northwest
and he loves small batch organic coffee
and micro brews and nirvana and i go to
this audition and i i thought i crushed
it
i read it once through they all say
thank you i leave and i'm walking back
to my car and the casting director runs
after me and he goes uh hey man they
really want you to do it again
uh this time with an indian accent
and yeah that was pretty typical in
those days interesting if it was written
indian they probably wanted an accent if
the part wasn't written indian they
didn't quite know what to do with you
and also usually asked you to do it with
an accent
which is weird because you know
obviously an accent in and of itself is
not a stereotype plenty of people have
accents
it's just that oftentimes an accent
becomes reductionist and a replacement
for subpar writing for kids right right
the artist part of you is like oh this
is so lame i don't have any juice in
this scene i remember i walked in
i walked back into the audition and i
did i said something that i would i
would end up saying regularly i must
have said this in in in 100 auditions
where the producers said we'd like you
to do it again with an accent and i said
sure what kind of accent would you like
i can do irish scottish jewish that's
great i went through the whole
yes and they looked at me and kind of
they were not amused and like why don't
we just stick to indian um and so i i
kind of had this decision point where i
was like look here's the deal the the
professionalism here is that i have
every right to walk out and i could and
i could respectfully walk away and say
sorry i'm not looking to do something
like that
or i could do the accent and see if i
get the part and then if i get the part
decide if i want to take it and the
reality is i needed credits on my resume
and this job paid i think it was like
750 bucks yeah my rent each month was
550 because i'm sharing a room with my
buddy adam
so i did the accent i got home my agent
called and she goes you got the you got
the part and i said all right i need to
ask you for advice can you ask them if i
can play this part the way that i had
planned it like this small batch organic
coffee guy instead of uh you know
instead of stereotype prajeeb and she
gave me some goodbyes she said why don't
you want to take the job because you
know you got to take it anyway and why
don't you just pull the director aside
in the morning
and ask if you can do it without the
accident so i i go in a little early to
sabrina the teenage witch
i find find the director he was like
standing next to the coffee cart and i
said hey man um really funny script i
mean it's not that funny but yeah
that's like really funny script man uh
you gotta get in the door
yeah exactly uh and i said i was just
hoping maybe you know i could i could
play him without the indian accent i
just i i prepared this whole backstory
that i thought could kind of be funny
and i gotta be honest with you i didn't
really see people like me growing up
when when you know when i would watch tv
and i thought maybe it'd be really cool
to kind of play against time that way
good for you and he said uh he was very
annoyed he goes no we hired you to do
the accent that's what you're gonna do
so i said i have two young cousins
they're nine and ten years old and they
love your show
and i know what it feels like to not see
people who look like me on screen and to
only see a stereotype and i was i was i
just was really hoping that maybe i'd
have the chance to play the part in a
way that's a little different and it's
still really funny
and he goes well i gotta tell you
uh your cousins should feel really lucky
that you're allowed to be on tv to begin
with and so should you and he walks off
oh thank god so it's not true that
racism comes from ignorance there's also
a foreign
inherent means
in somebody's marrow yeah totally i was
like oh we just that's just something
that that we tell ourselves to feel
better about racism
i did the part the way he wanted i mean
i was a guest on their show you know
what i mean it was not up to me to i
could have could i have left of course i
could have still left i love what we do
so much especially as comic actors
my uh instinct is i feel like the reason
that shows like sabrina the teenage
witch were like that aside from the fact
that you had guys like that directing
episodes who were awful humans yeah yeah
like the way network tv and lazy too
you're right you said that earlier
exactly it's also like [ __ ] un it's
unfunny it's like it's so
childish and and
uh lazy to reduce somebody somebody is
as gifted as you are as such a great
comedian to reduce them to a voice you
know when i hear people talk about how
like oh you just can't make certain
jokes today because of the left or
because people are too woke or it's too
politically correct i was like well it's
not that people are too woke or
politically correct it's that the jokes
you're proposing are [ __ ] lazy yeah
you're just not funny we've heard those
jokes a million times before people want
something that's a fresh take look it's
what i love about what we do as as
storytellers and it's one of the things
i'm so happy about the way that
hollywood has has evolved so that's the
that's the reason i tell somebody these
stories it's really inspiring that
you're able now to
shape the narrative and you're able to
provide uh that that thing that you were
hoping to provide when you were doing
sabrina the teenage witch you have the
power to um to change those things and
you have i mean your very presence in
these movies uh as as a funny actor much
more so than than a south asian actor i
think has has done
huge things in terms of moving that that
needle well thanks man you know i i
really feel indebted to the there are so
many uh people who came before me you
know that old that old adage of like the
the people whose shoulders we get to
stand on and in in our case there were
lots who whose names we may never know
like of course we all know sarita
chowdhury who's in in mississippi masala
denzel or ajay do but there's even a
there at least two or three generations
of of asian american actors before them
whose names we don't necessarily know i
mean i remember being a kid watching
margaret cho
and just being floored that there was
somebody who looked like her who told
such authentic biting stories yeah as
stand-up comedy and then you look at it
now and it's like there's so many people
um just because the opportunities are
there and that's awesome you in
particular i think because of the we had
mentioned those comedies in the in the
mid 2000s those were being seen by a lot
of like bros just like those kids at
that your school when you did the tin
man um you're you're doing it like on
mass now and harold and kumar was like a
it was a huge college movie and a stoner
movie a comedy that like a lot of frat
guys for lack of a better term
saw and loved when harold and kamar go
to white castle came out i remember um
you know the the kind of the mainstream
thought in hollywood was we don't know
if america is ready for two asian
american men to to head up uh buddy
comedy
and i think from our perspective it was
like well this seems ridiculous we feel
like any audience is going to want to
watch two characters who are appealing
who are funny who have a journey that
you can relate to yes it's a movie about
hamburgers and marijuana and we happen
to be asian-american but really the
story's about buddies it's about
friendship yeah and uh and the movie
comes out it tanked at the box office
and
the that monday
you know the phone wasn't ringing the
only conversations were see we told you
that two asian american men couldn't
really
uh lead a buddy comedy and
i can't remember how many weeks or
months went by but then the movie comes
out on hbo and on dvd with no marketing
and the fans found it
and they went out and bought the dvd
they gifted it to each other and it was
not just new york san francisco l.a
chicago it was des moines it was
arkansas milwaukee alabama oklahoma like
like you were saying like like frat bros
and charity girls
and people who
hollywood had written off i mean forget
about us yeah conversation like hey we
got to show diversity in communities
that may not have had it in real life
but i even think what what we proved
wrong was hollywood's archaic way of
doing business where they're the ones
who thought they're the ones who started
middle america totally they were looking
at the wrong numbers yes outside of l.a
these people won't watch
anything that's funny unless it's got
only white people in it it's like we
just don't think that's true as
comedians
we think that our audience is everywhere
and they are you know and with like
college kids who are more open-minded in
general and stoners too who want to see
something funny i mean like stoners
don't really i think the the like
when you're stone when i'm stoned i want
to see something funny you know i want
to like eat my face off i want to just
eat crap and i want to watch something
funny and and um and i think that was
true of a lot of people i think that's
how probably why it was discovered in
that way and
um
and and i i love that that happened
because it's another example of as as
you talk about in in your childhood that
humor can overwhelm any kind of like
prejudice like that or any kind of
preconceived notion about people it was
just a funny movie i i i love that
example and i love that then um people
started seeing you as a funny person and
casting you in that one of the questions
i get all the time is like hey man do
you get called kumar and uh and uh oh
man do people just offer you weed all
the time
and the answer to both of those is yes
people do call me kumar all the time and
people offer me weed constantly on the
street strangers who i don't know and if
your presumption is that that that i
should feel negatively about that you're
crazy and the shitty jobs i've had your
major job hazard is that somebody wants
to throw love at you because of a
character and offer you free weed yeah
well they are complaining about well i
know i i've witnessed this with you
specifically and the irony is um i think
i've gotten your sloppy seconds because
you don't really smoke much i you that
you and john are different in that right
because i
i know you both a bit and um so john was
kind of like the more uptight one in
those movies and you were like
you were the stoner and in reality it's
a little it's like kind of the reverse
right dude it's one of the reasons i
love playing kumar it's why i want to
keep doing those kinds of movies he's so
much cooler than i will ever be and i'm
not a method actor but for each one of
those three movies we've done by the
second week i am relaxed in real life
yeah i'm just like because i've spent my
days being this relaxed concept that's
interesting oh it's wild yeah that's
interesting
does it make you then want to
i mean can't you apply that to life like
what if i just i'm not to say like you
should just start smoking a lot of weed
but like yes you know dab you
you can apply my one of the first
lessons that i failed in my dad uh you
were asking about high school my dad
used to say for the longest time he was
like you know you
you can memorize lines for a school play
then why don't you just try to memorize
this chemistry equation why don't you
just try to memorize geometry and i'd
always say to them it's because geometry
has no plot you know it's easy to
memorize lines because there's a plot to
a scene yeah you're telling a story
yes yes and so i remember he once goes
uh
uh we'll make up a story for geometry
and it'll it'll stick so i went to i was
in the bathroom one evening brushing my
teeth i was probably 15.
um you know like no shirt gym shorts i'd
eaten a big dinner and i remember
staring at my stomach and my nipples
thinking
oh the
circumference of a circle or whatever
like pi r squared
and uh and uh you know a triangle yeah
that's what it was i was looking at
nipples going a triangle one half base
times height
and so i start creating this character
where i was like grabbing my
chest
going oh yeah you want you want
like this little baby little baby in
mommy's tummy yeah you want you want
milk from mommy's one half base times
height boobies right you little pie r
squared baby
and i i did it over and over again and i
didn't realize there was no zone i got
louder and louder oh man
i look up and standing behind me in the
mirror are my parents no you're just
furious what are you doing going to come
i didn't think i could be even more
turned off by math than i was
than i was before
um i don't know how now to pivot to
obama but i want to but it's but i was
going to say because
i knew you to be such a bright person um
just having known you outside of the the
industry uh but i i that must have
surprised a lot of people who did who
did associate you with kumar who these
stoner movies um when you made the
decision to leave acting and go with
actually work in the administration work
in in the white house
can you tell people how that came about
like what what was that process like and
again i i think a lot of people were
i know you know this they were surprised
by that um because of the the perception
they had of you at the time
my invitation to that was olivia wilde
so yes
house together she had a plus one to an
obama event in october of 2007.
um and all she said was you know do you
want to come with me and i said no not
really
any interest and she explained it was
going to be like a small 50 person
artist event where obama who was at that
point down 30 points in the polls before
the iowa caucuses yeah was going to
speak oh that's interesting cal i'm
sorry to interrupt but i i just assumed
having read the beginning of the book um
it sounds like you come from a family of
of you know real freedom fighters people
who show up and and marched with gandhi
and i love those stories about your
both grandfathers of yours who um who
were active in the in the peace movement
with gandhi i i read that and i thought
oh that makes perfect sense because cal
just seems to have this inherent passion
for
social justice and you were so
articulate about it back then it seemed
so well versed so i just assumed that
that's where it came from i didn't know
that friend of the show olivia wilde
was your real introduction to it that's
interesting it's a little bit both in
the sense that yep i mean my my
grandparents marched with gandhi in the
indian independence movement and those
were the stories we heard as kids
growing up a lot you know
especially my grandfather who was beaten
and jailed by the british and had scars
on his legs and and
the byproduct of that i think in our
house was that the family value was to
do the right thing politics to me was a
separate thing i think i i didn't really
have an interest in politicians
so
i knew i was going to this event with
olivia i knew it was going to be like 50
musicians actors etc
and i knew that by virtue of that event
like people were going to ask questions
about the arts right because we're all
artists we're going to ask about nea
funding they'd probably ask about arts
in schools so i thought i want to ask a
question that's not about the arts so i
go on obama's campaign website and i'm
reading about climate change and i see
that he's he wants to invest in ethanol
i remember that a couple of months prior
i had read an article in that in this
magazine called foreign affairs
which is this like big thick magazine
that you find at the airport or
subscribe to sort of like the economist
like you don't see the economist around
unless you subscribe to it yeah uh or
you see it at the airport so
it's that you definitely don't see a lot
of actors reading it
right no offense actors yeah correct no
offense to actors but uh but yeah i was
i was an anomaly and i'm a foreign fair
subscriber and this article said uh it
talked about how if we invest in uh corn
to turn into ethanol for fuel it's gonna
drive up the price of corn for people in
developing countries and rely on it for
food right um and so it could result in
a lot of people going hungry so i
thought boom that's my question that's
my smarty fans question for this uh
senator obama art submit this guy who's
30 points down in the polls and thinks
he can be president so i go with olivia
it's an open bar i probably have three
glasses of wine obama's making the
rounds
and comes over and stands next to me and
olivia and says hey how are you and i
said senator i've got a question for you
go ahead
hey senator how are you i'm very good
very good come on i enjoy your movies uh
harold and
or kumar
yeah
very surreal uh
i i said you know uh senator i you know
i read your climate change uh plan i saw
that you're investing heavily in did you
turn into ethanol
indeed we're trying that's what we're
trying
this is this is going to be tough
because now you know punchline which is
the next no this is great the
next
the next part is the punchline which was
i said uh you know i said well sir you
know um you know if you if you invest in
in corn to turn in ethanol you know i
want to just rise the uh raise the price
of of corn for people in developing
countries who rely on it for food yeah
yeah and i'm i'm looking at them all
proud like i i got you
i got you i've got a great question and
he just looks at me and he goes uh oh
yeah i i read that article on foreign
affairs too
and uh you know if you read if you read
my campaign website carefully you would
have seen that i'm investing in
corn-based ethanol as a bridge to
cellulosic ethanol so that we can create
fuel from things like grass clippings
and leaves from our front lawns one day
and he smirks and he walks to the next
person and olivia mike drops me yes yeah
and it's like oh [ __ ] you just got
scared by barack obama and at that point
i was like i don't know what part of my
hubris as an actor made me think that i
might somehow know more than somebody
who sits on the senate foreign relations
committee well because there are a lot
of
yeah i don't want to say it but um i
think more often than not you would be
right to presume that but there are a
lot of empty politicians
but then you got to think uh then that
must have inspired you to want to get
involved with his campaign in particular
yeah yeah olivia and i signed up that
night to volunteer and we did
we did our the first uh the first obama
surrogate trip was myself olivia and
megalin ichi
we did it yes
how did it transform how did you go from
that to i'm going to stop acting for a
little while because i know how much you
love acting
what was that journey like so after that
year and a half on the on the campaign
you know obama becomes the the
president-elect and
and this email goes out with with some
of the staffers that says if you want to
apply
for a job in the administration fill out
a resume and an application and upload
it to a website called change.gov that
we've uh assembled yeah and so i thought
you know what i i i've just spent a year
more than a year telling young people in
26 states who they should vote for and
why
if i'm qualified shouldn't i try to
actually
help this guy execute the things that we
promised all these people he would do so
i filled out this application i uploaded
it to change.gov i only told my manager
who in the in the audiobook uh from my
book called you can't be serious you
can't be serious you can't be serious
he goes he goes
so he's the only person i told that i
had put my resume on change.gov and
nobody called so november nobody calls
and then in january i get a phone call
saying hey um
there's a concert on the st inauguration
concert on the steps of the lincoln
memorial you've been invited to be part
of the speaking program so basically
they had a bunch of really famous
musicians and then actors would read
short interstitial quotes from previous
presidents so president-elect obama
comes through meets my parents my
brother my manager they're all very
friendly and then mrs obama comes
through and i had not met her before
um i assume
how are you [ __ ]
i've heard a lot about you barack obama
barack obama meeting would really be
next level dreams in fact maybe that's
the animated tv show that i've got
everyone's asking if i want to turn the
book into into like a netflix series i
was like oh that's funny so i think the
animated series
yeah totally totally so mrs obama says
uh what i thought she was saying to
everybody which was well i hope you stay
involved and my manager standing next to
me goes well you know he applied for a
job right
oh my god and
i was like yo yo yo no no no this is not
the time
yeah stop yeah and she goes oh what do
you mean my manager goes yeah yeah he
applied for a job at the white house and
nobody even called him back
and at this point mrs obama looks at me
and just goes uh
what are you talking about who who did
you apply with
and i said
oh i just i didn't want to bother
anybody i just put my resume on
change.gov and as soon as those words
came out of my mouth
i just i felt like an idiot mostly
because she gave me this look
that you give somebody if they like drop
a piece of pizza cheese side down on the
floor and then pick it up and eat it
it's just like a little disgust yeah a
little disgust a little confusion a
little certain
concern yeah all of those things she
gives me that look and she goes hey
barack oh man come here
and brings the president-elect back over
she looks at me and she goes
she goes
tell him what you just told me
and i was like oh no no no no no no no
no no tell him tell him what you told me
so i was like oh okay well sir you know
mr president i was just i was just
saying you know i applied for a job at
the white house in case there was
anything that i would be
useful doing i'd be happy to do it i
just you know i i don't know if yeah i
would be qualified patton and he goes oh
he called reggie love his his i love
reggie over yeah he's awesome yes and he
said uh he said reggie do you guys have
each other's info and i said yeah we do
we text often enough we have each
other's info he said well let me you
know let's look into it and we'll we'll
have somebody call you i had no idea
that you'd actually be interested and
they were looking for somebody in the
office of public engagement to handle
youth outreach asian american outreach
and outreach to the arts community and
had checked
they only had the salary to hire one
person this is one of the reasons they
hadn't hired anybody yet was they were
trying to find somebody to be a
multi-hyphenate
with that one salary and uh
and so it just worked out and i couldn't
think of a reason to say no like
what do i say i'm sorry mr president i
have another stoner movie to make i
cannot serve my country but here's a
great twist that stoner movie that when
it did then come around to do the third
one
was who was who was first on board who
was like most supportive
a very leading question i thought i
would just serve uh in the white house
for a year but learned obviously very
quickly that a lot of the legislative
items that were trying to get done at
the white house weren't getting done in
a year so then i decided to extend for a
second year
and right around the time that i decided
to extend we get this phone call that's
like hey great news they're making the
third harold and kumar movie and i said
that's awesome but they're gonna have to
wait a year because i'm i'm not acting
right now yeah he calls me back and he's
like so um i just want you to know
they said we just got this nasty letter
that said that you'd be considered in
breach of contract if you didn't show up
since they have a start date for the
third harold and kamar
so he's like my advice to you would be
to just do the movie and i was like i
don't understand where all this beef is
coming from i love this character i love
like i know the studio folks yes yeah
but i was like i love these [ __ ]
people i told my my direct bosses that
what was going on they said i'm sorry i
am going to have to keep the one-year
timeline i can't extend
and it just so happened that that week i
was uh briefing the president on
something related to young people and
yeah i mentioned at the end of the
briefing i was like sir by the way you
know i just want to let you know this
might be my last my last month or two
were you nervous to say that to him cal
were you nervous to tell him like i'm
i'm leaving i don't know i don't think i
was nervous i think i was just more like
bummed out but also i just wanted to be
thankful for the experience to serve our
country for the yeah and almost
apologetic that i didn't get to stick
through yeah um the important things
that i was entrusted with with helping
uh be a small part of you know like i
would have liked to have been there to
see through some of the big legislative
items right so that was kind of my tone
he must have said something like um
why so i was like well sir you know
they're making a third harold and kamar
movie and i have a pre-existing contract
and i
uh you know they'll sue me uh they've
threatened to sue me if i don't show up
yeah to do the movie and that would
obviously be really distracting
um and he just said something like uh
well i mean we can't have you getting
sued
besides i mean those are really funny
movies yeah yeah can you just can you do
that and then just come back
yes is that a is that a thing i can do
and he said well yeah i mean how long i
haven't you told me those movies are
super short yeah yeah it's only like six
weeks he's like well yeah so then do
what you need to do and then uh why
don't you come back so basically i you
know i had to leave without the
expectation that i'd get my job back but
i could apply as soon as i left
because then i would have a start date
right like yeah yeah hey i know i left
this job yesterday but like here's my
resume because it's going to be applied
for six weeks i'd like to i'm available
on this date and i have experience and i
have but not just experience i also have
a security clearance i have the
background check i have a lot of stuff
that's done so there were other people
who were able to cover it was also i
think we shot it over the summer which
thankfully since i was working on youth
outreach
people are out of college there's a
little it's a little lighter
of the season um and i was able to shoot
harold and kamar and then come back go
back oh wow white house and justin
nobody knows nobody knows that story
that's uh oh wow that's hey oh
that's how i was able to to do both you
can't do both at the same time but how
crazy we're all really supportive it was
cool i love that he's into those movies
obama's extremely connected to pop
culture he loves his comedies i think
that the phrasing is like you know the
stuff that reminds me of my old days
which he wrote about very transparently
in his first two books like right i'm
also remembering i don't know if you
were there's a total non-sequitur but do
you remember the
bernie event in l.a i want to say it was
2016
maybe early 2016 was that was the
concert the chili peppers no this was a
small event at somebody's house
um and it was like a chance for bernie
to hear from it was 2016 so maybe they
were called influencers at that point
but it was just like anybody creative on
on messaging ideas uh for the primary
but somebody said you know senator uh do
you know what vine is
i think bernie said something like
course i know what vine is
vine yeah the six seconds let me tell
you something young people need an
attention span more than six seconds
young people need to understand that
policy is complicated i will not put
something as short as six seconds you
cannot possibly the disparity in wealth
that exists cannot be put in six seconds
and i just remember being like i i i i
love him with a lot of him on policy and
he is just so not barack obama
obama would have been different
deliveries yeah
obama would have been like my own
account yes yes yeah exactly well my
daughter's coming into a binder
right life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
life is short listeners wonder is even
the rich podcast is doing a two-part
series on the bizarre and fascinating
kidnapping of paddy hurst and you won't
want to miss it
one night in 1974 19 year old college
student patty hearst who happened to be
the heir to the hearst newspaper fortune
was kidnapped from her berkeley
apartment she was kept in a closet for
weeks while her captors made their
demands then after two months in
captivity and a completely unexpected
twist patty announced that her name was
tanya and was seen on video robbing a
bank with her captors the new season of
even the rich explores different
theories about what actually happened to
patti was she brainwashed or was she the
victim of stockholm syndrome listen to
even the rich on apple podcasts amazon
music or you can listen one week early
and add free by joining wondering plus
in the wondery app hey life is short
listeners business wars is a podcast
from wondering that brings you the full
stories behind some of the biggest
business battles in history in their new
season you'll hear about the fight
between espn vs fox sports to dominate
the sports television industry espn is
the american cable network that plays
the trail for around the clock sports
coverage athletes even change the way
they play just to get on sportscenter's
nightly highlight reels but right around
the corner rupert murdoch's fox sports
channel started gaining on espn in the
us the sports tv business is worth more
than 12 billion dollars the question is
who will come out on top fox sports or
espn listen to business wars espn versus
fox sports on apple podcast amazon music
or you can listen one week early and add
free by joining wondering plus in the
wondery app
hello hello
[Music]
we have a lightning round if you'll
indulge me i know i've already taken a
lot of time
okay um
you were supposed to say oh you can't be
serious oh you can't serious just along
uh what is your favorite emoji
i mean the the
there are three they go in sequence it's
the
the fist the eggplant and the rain
of course that's silly me yeah dr jane
goodall had the same answer yeah reason
why i can't run for office
we heard on justin podcast that after a
story about [ __ ] on d yeah after saying
[ __ ] time all right you know what if we
can't use that one then we'll use tacos
because that's my favorite food
okay well we were getting to that um we
used to ask snack food do you have a
snack food like i mean you are uh an
ambassador for the stoner culture um
what what what would a stone snack of
yours be
i mean i just i love tacos yeah for any
reason any purpose any reason you must
get sick of this but do you do you enjoy
a white castle burger is that um i gotta
tell you i used to i'm not a big fast
food eater and ever since
uh i will give them a huge shout out
they uh
they introduced an impossible burger a
couple years ago and it is fantastic i
like impossible meat yeah me too yes
plate-based burgers they're they have
their sliders so you you can
indulge after as much as you're smoking
and drinking before you walk into that
establishment yes but they're they're
delicious great call cal yeah um who was
your first celebrity crush would you say
candace cameron
oh wow okay oh no oh oh i'm thinking
sabrina is uh no that's so
listen to joan hart
okay
candace cameron i remember being candace
cameron yeah what about you um i it's i
meg ryan was a big one um
uh carrie fisher i'm trying to uh make
ryan i would i would say was my number
number one there were a lot though
there were many what is your um bow
derek what is your favorite ice cream
flavor
it's not about me
mint chocolate chip oh my god so we just
started we just implemented this
question this very hard hitting
controversial controversial question and
you are the second person i've asked and
um
you are the second person who said mint
chocolate chip i i oh no way
love
uh so it was yesterday and it was um amy
mann one of my favorite singers oh yeah
amy matt but she said
she she made it sound like it was more
controversial she said i know this is
this can be i think that's how she even
prefaced it i know this isn't
controversial but i um and i said what's
controversial about mint chocolate chips
and she planted this seed in my head
which is a lot of people think they
don't want to feel like they've just
brushed their teeth when they eat ice
cream oh
sure i'm not trying to prove to anybody
why they should or shouldn't no no no i
know this is your
i love it
i've heard all that um what is what is
your favorite holiday cal
um thanksgiving yeah and you did you get
to spend with your family and the last
one you know i know you said i did yeah
we skipped we skipped that year but this
this year for thanksgiving we did and
that's the big you know
uh it's just such a
uh you eat a lot and spend time with
family who you know the best happy to
hang out with do you have a movie
tradition do you watch a certain thing
around this time of year
uh
no i mean look i think i i i'm a sucker
for christmas movies now yeah um and and
i the the period between uh thanksgiving
and
christmas is usually also where diwali
falls which is the festival of light in
uh oh in hindu uh several yeah hinduism
buddhism jainism and a couple others
depending on sort of a pan
eastern holiday for
lack of a much better phrase than i'm
sure exists but it's basically it's it
symbolizes light overcoming darkness
um so and it's a festival of light some
similar hanukkah i guess but so it's
it's like back to back holidays it's
diwali you i know i grew up in a
probably jewish town so hanukkah and
it's it's such a cool time of year um
and i just produced sorry i should have
met good no no no yeah i was just going
to say you seemed so intrigued by the
jewish faith by by all the um you loved
going to the services and you loved how
personal those yeah those sermons were
um i i love that again you it's you
can't be serious you detail all of it so
i won't rehash you here but wait sorry
you you what'd you say you you went to
what yeah you i just produced a diwali
themed buddy comedy for comedy central
comes out december 11th oh wow and it'll
rerun it's called hot mess holiday about
these two women um who go on it's
basically a diamond heist story and the
backdrop is diwali in christmas so it's
their their first diwali movie it's
reminiscent of uh i i have to underscore
it's on comedy central it's not a uh
it's it's not like a hallmark christmas
movie oh yeah admittedly i'm a sucker
for that yeah but it's much more like in
the vein of like a bridesmaids kind of a
thing speaking of movies what's an
acclaimed movie that you haven't seen
that people kind of give you [ __ ] for oh
man there are a lot i have to say i
there's so much i haven't seen
i haven't seen uh princess bride oh wow
okay that's a big one yeah that's a big
one that'll that i hear all the time
it's one of those movies like i haven't
seen people yeah i haven't even seen the
princess i know i know you haven't seen
it i know
i have a few of those too but it's like
okay but you know can i ask what you're
what you waiting for waiting for it yeah
why not it's on all the time
okay all right well maybe this solid i'm
excited see when i hear that i mean i
get excited for the person because yeah
god i know you know yeah i or it's been
hyped up too much and you're like uh
right yeah no no i think it sounds like
i'd like you'll love it um what is a
what is a game show pastor present i
think we've been on game shows together
um that you would want to be a
contestant on
oh man um
[Music]
okay why haven't you been on jeopardy
could have you been on jeopardy
no i have not but i i don't think i'm
smart enough to oh i in jeopardy
disagree
um
you know what i'll tell you it's uh
uh
truth or dare on nickelodeon back in the
day yes yes with mark summers the uh
yeah yes i would want to get slimed i
think yeah totally oh that would be fun
um
how do you drink your coffee or tea
black
black okay uh if you if you could learn
another language you mentioned the ones
that you do know um
what would it be do you think
uh probably either spanish or mandarin
they're both gonna be super useful did
you ever talk to those horror shippers
for former uh for i guess a friend of
the show maggie q i know you guys did
designated survivor together did you
ever talk to her about her experience
with mandarin and cantonese she that she
spoke oh she spoke cantonese uh having
done a lot of movies in hong kong and um
she had to learn mandarin for some other
movie a historical like historic epic
and
and she said it was like it was more
difficult than i would have thought well
mandarin cantonese the same kind of
potential
it's supposed to be yeah it's pretty
supposedly harder than learning english
um right
what is your favorite cereal cow oh
uh
lucky charms okay yeah great did were
your parents pretty healthy growing up
were they uh they forbid food like that
yeah well we had it you know those
cereals are all fortified with vitamins
right so
it's a weird thing because the sugar
content is ridiculous but they're all
they also do have that's true they're
good for you in that in that sense so
it's a yeah you can't have it every day
maybe yeah they like trojan horse
vitamins into you with like you know
like really sweet trojan oils um
if you have to choose a different first
name um in fact cal i should tell people
um maybe people don't know this that you
were born kal penn kalpen suresh modi
modi's
uh but then you just i mean it makes
sense yeah you would wanna
that might be difficult for a lot of us
uh clumsy white people to say
um
was that the green name the uh
yeah
it was one of the impetuses the the the
the full stories in my audiobook okay go
ahead okay it's a there's a there's a
story about how we were it's like at 2
30 in the morning at fat burger off of
westwood boulevard
uh
i know that fat burger is in iowa of
course it's yeah yeah um and my college
boys were like well you know whoopi
goldberg's name isn't really whoopi
goldberg right and i was like what do
you mean what's her name like it's karen
johnson get out of here
think about it why would she be called
whoopi goldberg her name is karen
johnson i didn't know this either uh
chevy chase his name is apparently
cornelius and he changed it to chevy and
their whole argument was like you need a
catchy name both of them have great
names and they they're like they
wouldn't be uh as successful if they had
normal people names um so that combined
with the questions about typecasting and
and getting my foot in the door let me
come up with that well my real name is
demetrius fontaine
i should have um i wish that would be
true i know me too
if if but what would you choose cal if
you needed a different first name
i mean i now i want demetrius clearly
okay yeah you can have it um if you had
to have a sandwich named after if you
got to have i should say a sandwich
named after you at a your favorite deli
it's the cow pen what what would be on
it i'm a real big fan of a little little
southern drawl
and when that happens i'm called calpian
and so i just think it'd be fun to have
like a cow peanut butter and jelly
sandwich oh that's great kale peanut
yeah keal there's there's an interview i
did with a radio station in memphis last
week and the guy was awesome and so
funny and it was such a such a great
accessory wonderfully southern bit he
did he goes uh my next guest calpian is
um you might know him from uh harold and
kumar uh do whatever it is they're gonna
do and uh yeah and i was like i [ __ ]
love you
such a great great bit that is great and
it is true it's like those movies could
be called that at this point yeah the
important part is not the white castle
it's the herald and kumar yes exactly
um uh if what what is your favorite tom
hanks movie big
yeah um also uh amy mance you have a lot
of similarities with amy man um would
you rather take a time machine to the
past or the future
future
this was this is a question that always
used to come up in like fifth grade or
seventh grade right like when you're a
kid
and we we like to have those kind of
questions on the show every i'm curious
if this you know what
how long has this how long has that
question been part of the uh this is the
second time we've asked it it's it's
we're changing over the new year yeah
over time i'm curious to know so
uh
my guess is that uh all the white folks
are gonna be evenly split and i think
is to say the future right
right there's a great bit it's by a
stand-up comedian who is now
considered problematic so i don't want
to mention his name but he has a bit
about yeah how how white people you go
back to any time period and it's like
you're okay
you know but it is not true i remember
being conscious of that as a kid i was
like
passed no
i would get beaten why would i do that
totally oh my god british colonialism no
way nothing are you are you a uh are you
a talker or a texter more of a talk like
when you want to communicate
oh
i
i'm a texter but i no that's not true i
have so many on red text i'm a talker
yeah um you're a good talker
are you a knight or morning person
uh
really depends on the circumstance so
i'll go morning for now okay um beach or
mountains would you prefer
vacation beach um
uh toilet roll over or under
ah
doesn't matter
yeah same with amy mann she was like i
don't care at all um i do have a
preference that it should go over um
but uh who cares not about me
in the apartment my hole is clean oh
crap
great i'm just kidding i just want to be
oh she said the same thing
i assumed it would be um
uh finished finish this what if that's
all it is what if that's the the
takeaway that's the question you know
that you're gonna you could easily
do
22 reasons why calpin could never run
for office yes totally yeah and then i
was like i'm sorry my whole being clean
means i can't run for office i know it
should be the opposite i would lead with
that that would be my campaign promise i
promise to make everyone's hole clean um
finish finish this sentence life is
short so
do what you want to do
yeah okay
is that what everybody says though no uh
this is also a new question and we're
kind of um i
i that's a tough one i mean we end the
lightning round with that because i know
it kind of brings things to uh we like
ending we like the gears to grind down
awkwardly on the
show
um but i like that cal yeah and you are
such a great example of that that you
again not to labor the point but um you
overcame a lot of a lot to be where you
are now and and i'm so glad you did
because i've so enjoyed your work i've
enjoyed your friendship thank you i've
really enjoyed this yeah same
[Music]
so so that just happened yeah oh that's
selling ryan phillippe that's a little
too philippe yeah well yeah cal is not
quite so you do a thing with your lips
right now you do your ryan phillips
shrine yeah ryan has um his lips are
kind of like we've covered that we've
covered that yeah but this is cal and
cal doesn't necessarily sound like that
but he has pillowy lips as well he does
he does maybe that's why i was doing it
i was making my lips more pillowy what a
guy what a guy right i mean what a smart
accomplished yeah
very smart soothing voice i liked that
he gave little snippets of his book
like he didn't he told little he took
like kind of cliff's notes versions of
some of these really good stories yeah
it made me want to read his book cow's
notes yes cal's notes and
but more than read this book it made me
want to listen to his book because his
voice oh yeah is mellifluous he does he
sounds a bit like obama he does does he
yeah he's very um
he's really easy to listen to yes he's a
beautiful voice yeah he really draws you
in with that those tones those dulcet
tones um and then of course the the con
this you know sub the
and then of course the substance of what
he's saying
is um really compelling i mean he's
substance yeah oh i didn't listen to
anything he said i was just interested
no of course i'm kidding yeah yeah
substance galore great storyteller and
those but that book is chock full of
those stories
and talk about a guy who
overcame a lot you know like the
perseverance he had
and the ambition and the work ethic and
i also think he's probably too humble to
receive a compliment like this but i i
would say that
those i mean harold and kumar for
example is
that was before that was long enough ago
now that it was before the sweeping
changes that are happening now were
taking place
so i oh yeah i would say he was oh yeah
i would say he was somewhat of a
trailblazer yes for
the asian community is that fair to say
yeah i think in fact it's changed
so rapidly and in in a good direction
um but it's it's been such a huge change
that i think people might might
need to hear that you know be reminded
of that because you're right it was a
totally different situation well and to
the point that all the studio people
about harold and kumar when that came
out they were all antis they're all
wondering if a movie
carried by two asian actors would be
something that people would watch and
sure enough yeah i didn't know this it
bombed at the box office yes and then it
you know it had legs yeah and it took
off on video and stuff but
but that was something that people
for the most part american audiences
weren't so i mean certainly used to yeah
and maybe not ready for that that
happened to a lot of popular comedies um
that was the case with
austin powers the first austin powers
didn't do that well at the box office
but then on video people discovered it
it happened with mcgruber we've talked
about um jon show would be a good guess
too he would be jon show would be good
for this show
i knew you're gonna do that i saw your
eyes like drift away
i tried to find the pun by the way
speaking of puns that was really made me
laugh
no that you were talking about that
toronto raptor seek fan oh yeah yeah so
he's seeking attention
that was a good one
he's got a cool story i want to watch
yeah so when i first heard that
announced i was just like huh what is
that going to be i i wasn't wasn't
negative about it but i just thought i
was confused a little bit that they were
making an entire movie about a fan
because you assumed all he did was go to
wrap your scan yes it's like yeah you
didn't consider that he had a life
outside of that stadium no i know i just
thought
it's a movie about a mega fan
but it's i can't wait to see the movie
it's gonna be good uh his burning
impression is very funny that was really
funny and i love that bernie did god
every time i hear a bernie story or
something like it makes me love him
really funny that he like is outraged by
the idea of seven seconds that's it six
seconds of it's way too that's too
christopher lloyd yeah um it's funny
though there's not enough time
he's right it's right i know to really
to adequately describe the disparity
yeah it's not enough time
surprised he hasn't seen princess bride
he should see it i know but he wants to
shame him well that's the thing when i
ask that question now i have to be
prepared to not be incredulous
it's tough it's ironic because the
question is who's incredulous
no
and then i'm hurt
i mean like
the thing about that is and i like i
haven't seen all of dirty dancing so i
can't tugs that's on tv a lot too but
you saw you've seen some of it i've seen
some of it you've just seen the dirty
dancing part yes i've just seen the
patrick swayze stuff um i haven't seen
or citizen kane you know this here's the
thing i haven't had
i know i'm going to get here we go i
drag
for this but but i haven't had an
overwhelming desire to see pretty woman
that's why i haven't seen it every woman
in my life
has gotten
some degree of obsession with me from
not having seen pretty woman yeah you
don't both have to make women upset by
the fact that you haven't seen pretty
woman yeah and at this point it's kind
of like
maybe the reason i haven't seen that
movie is because i like
i kind of like having that you know it's
kind of fun to have people it's like
your fifth night jeopardy story
oh no it's like my 17th night no
speaking of jeopardy amy schneider oh we
should
what a role she's on we got to get her
on i bet kel penn would be good on
jeopardy oh yeah
i'm surprised he hasn't done celebrity
jeopardy i think he'd be good on real
jeopardy celebrity jeopardy they kind of
dumb it down a little bit did you know
that um
did you know that whoopi goldberg's name
was karen johnson
no crazy crazy
crazy yeah then i looked it up because i
thought but it makes sense i thought
surely he's wrong so i googled it
and
the one thing like the one saving grace
is that karen is spelled in kind of a
cool way it's a k posture no it's
c-a-r-y-n
c-a-r-y-n okay so it's like kind of cool
alternative sounding yeah it's also
aaron johnson
especially now with with what is
happening with the name karen i know i
think about that with karen's i think
about it
it must suck i know is that word it's
like a lot what is it two years maybe
that has taken off
karen's muscles as a term and parents
who name their kid karen must be
recently especially must be like oh
really i don't think babies are being
named karen recently no no no but like
now three-year-olds whoever was named
karen right before it became that's what
i'm saying but
i i think that name for babies has been
phased out you know be interesting you
don't meet any
four-year-old parents karen's also an
older it is that's true you know i it'd
be great to see like a chart to really
like
do the statistics on that um on names
like
karen or adolf or you know names that
become like immediately like bad mm-hmm
and just see
the how how drastically it did i wonder
if adolf was a very popular name at the
time i think it was really yes i heard
that it was it was like a not a very
popular name but like a fairly common
austrian name
joseph is still a very popular name and
stalin killed a lot more people i know
but i think joseph was so
popular it was like worldwide popular
there were so many josephs that like
i i think that that speaks to the
strength of the name joseph that that it
was able to overcome stalin pol pot you
don't mean many polls i wonder if poll
was a popular um cambodian word name
well we digress
should we read a letter yeah okay oh by
the way kel's name interesting that
kalpin kalpin yeah uh calvin modi um all
right
yeah yeah
uh and what was it it makes sense that
he would it's a very like
i like it's a great name it really flows
but it's it works as it as two names it
does it's strange to have to readjust to
it being one name i think like many
things in his career he made the right
call
how how impressive too sorry to
interrupt your thought that um
he made the right call in this case too
that he was able to put his foot down
uh when he was a young actor it's one
thing to do if you have power you know
and you have some like fame and success
status like that but to do that on when
you're just doing like a guest star on
sabrina the teenage yes queen ballsy yes
okay
i don't know if we should say ballsy
no i think the palsy's still okay he has
balls
that's true
yeah that's true from uh
i'm just thinking about his balls
all right maybe that you can't say no no
from
jennifer wittes w-i-t-t-e-s
subject my emotional support podcast hi
justin christian i found life is short
just a couple of months ago which is
actually great because it's comforting
to know that though i have already
listened to dozens of episodes there are
many more ahead of me to enjoy ah it's
so nice so nice that you're excited to
listen to more i jump around depending
on which guest suits my mood i love you
guys
ah thanks jennifer nice you have a
soothing effect on my busy working mom
life in fact my teenage daughter will
often catch me smiling or chuckling
along with the show and say things like
look at you living your best life
laughing with justin long
that's so nice
indeed
indeed if i haven't listened for a few
days it's like a breath of fresh air to
reconnect with you guys you feel like
pals especially i especially love to
listen while cooking dinner or endlessly
driving my kids to sports guitar etc
isn't it funny to imagine that she's
kind of like hanging out with us when
she's with her kids she's listening to
you talking about kal penn's balls
well
among other things yeah
one of the things i like best about the
show is that who you consider to be
icons in childhood mainstays are the
same for me
corey feldman fred savage ralph macchio
the delight and wonder you clearly feel
in asking about goonies karate kid
goodwill hunting and all the other
classics really hits home ah yeah it's
pure joy for me to revisit the most
important films and shows my life along
with you
on the note of our childhood pop culture
heroes i'm calling out friend of the
show jerry oh
oh yes best friend of the show yes best
bff of lis
who said uh who said he watches the real
housewives as a way to bond with his
wife i know it's more than that because
whenever i see him on andy cohen i i
agree with her he loves it
you would watch it if he was single yes
totally it's such that's such an excuse
that's like maybe like the fourth or
fifth reason he watches it uh back to
jennifer when i see him on andy cohen
going he's an absolute kid in the candy
store and possibly goes deeper on the
intricacies of the housewife franchise
than andy himself i'm glad it's a good
thing in his marriage but he's totally
all in come on jerry
i totally agree with her me too good
call jennifer yeah
come on sherry
i have a would you rather but first i'd
say that i loved ed ah i wish it was
streamable so i could share with my kids
is there a petition somewhere or
something
yeah this comes up a lot i know i
i
the music rights and um it was really
expensive but um i think that might be
it but there was another reason it was
like something to do with
uh
whatever the company that produced it it
was um okay viacom
tom cavanaugh friend of the show and
your neighbor now yes new neighbor i
don't wanna out him you just say his
dress yeah he's a neighbor well i gotta
go visit him he's got a basketball court
at his house yeah it's gonna be cool
okay
i have two this is back to jennifer okay
but me too saying okay i have two great
number one
would you rather always have to have a
super spicy breakfast no matter what
or a ridiculously sweet dinner that's a
great question oh i.e while on a data or
out with friends you are eating a banana
split while everyone else gets steak
i don't mind the sh the shame element of
it so much like no in fact if anything
that'd be kind of funny yeah if i did
that
but just in terms of like my own dietary
needs
it depends as long as the spicy like
super spicy was like something i could
get down and it would like give me like
a burning like stomach ulcer every day
i think you i would definitely pick that
if i could handle it if i may i think
your body would probably respond to it
accordingly
at first it would adjust that he would
adjust you're saying i would like into
the spiciness yeah yeah well yeah at
first your body would i don't want to
get into it reject certain things
in potentially aggressive ways yes it
would it would it would aggressively not
be able to process but if it was spicy
like spicy that i could tolerate and
then i could grow more tolerant of over
time i bet you would i would definitely
pick the spicy i would i would i mean
for one thing dinner is just more
important to me i care more about
yeah yeah yeah me breakfast is just like
a thing for me to like get fuel in my
body see what i would do is it with my
because i think immediately i think
about how important like veg vegetable
having because i have a lot of
vegetables in the beginning that they
have those green i have greens a green
smoothie i probably talk about too much
um but i would just make that
if this is if i can i would just make
that really spicy you just put a bunch
of cayenne pepper yeah it'd be gross at
first obviously and my body too you
might get used to it though but it would
be like a means to an end you know yes
which is how you see the because you
don't love the taste of the green
smoothies you have them because correct
me if i'm wrong they're healthy healthy
and i just want to put but dinner i know
i want to win health you want healthy
dinner but you also want a delicious
dinner yes it would be a spicy greenie
yeah a means to an end me too and and to
an to a mean end it would create a mean
end potentially yes at first and then
and then my end would hopefully
adjust your back your back end yes yes
um
number two would you rather live in a
world in which the wonder years never
existed oh boy i don't live in that
world well
or a world in which stand by me never
existed
oh that's easy for me
no offense to a best friend of the show
jerry o'connell i love stand by me but i
would definitely lose stand by me
that's harder for me for one thing i
there's
six seasons of the wonder years there's
so much more of it there's over 100
episodes no stand by me is one movie i
know and also wonder years was we
watched over the course of such a longer
period of time and it was it was more
formative for me mm-hmm as much as i
loved stamp by me i i couldn't lose
i couldn't lose wonder years
yeah but it would be
at this point in my life you know
another another reason to pick the
wonder years
is because i know st i've seen stand by
me so many times i know it oh in which
it never existed uh that's hard to
imagine stand by me also also helped me
like it made me want to do what they do
it made me kind of want to yeah i can
see that for you but also the one reason
to for me to pick um
keeping stand by me is because
if it weren't for stand by me jerry
o'connell best friend of the show might
not have become jerry o'connell that's
true and he might not be the best friend
of the show now and that would be and
one of our boys that would be a huge
loss it would be i i i so that's the
biggest consideration for keeping your
right standby
i hope jerry's listening he's definitely
listening
think i don't know i think he's busier
now with the with the talk
because he's that show is taking up a
lot of his time i think
but um you know sometimes when he calls
it it doesn't he talks about how much
time it takes up but then he's like
and what else what else it's like it
doesn't sound like yes he sounds like he
has time he's listening he's like
all right you know what [ __ ] it i'll
keep standing by me forever
me too and now you make a really good
point because jerry's important in my
life
so thanks jennifer and then she says
thanks for adding sunshine to my daily
grind that's so nice
that was great that was maybe a perfect
letter it was it was funny and very bad
at all
maybe that's my ego talking
it was just complimentary no but they
were good would you rather they were
great would you rather that was a really
good letter yeah two really good would
you rather yeah it was a good letter
yeah really good anyhoo
thank you jennifer that's nice
by the way sorry no sorry i was going to
say that jennifer set the bar pretty
high there
but it doesn't mean that
other people shouldn't try writing in at
life is short at wondering.com yeah well
i just keep thinking about like your
resolution to jerry on the show more
it is my resolution should we try him
now no my resolution is to plan to have
money all right because he's a busy guy
that's right he's doing the talk
i think almost every episode now you
when it's like
30 seconds away for being over you
suggest having jared yeah
well
because i don't i i it's always funny
that this isn't a three-hour podcast
yeah i know that's also joe rogan
and whenever i suggest it you your eyes
dart to the time that we've like how
long have we recorded and you think i
could see you doing the math like well
because jerry's gonna add an extra i
mean easy 30 minutes
no not that long but
oh what else um but um okay well thank
you everyone and thank god thanks cal my
old pal my old
my little pal pen
just pointed at me to take it and it's
right there it's right there my pal pen
cow pen
um
and uh and again yeah if you want to
write in and be uh pen pals cow pen pals
and
and check out cal's book i think you
should check out his audiobook but if
you prefer reading then
check out his book and read it yeah you
could check out both the name again
justin you can't be serious you forget
that's the name yeah but not that you
forget part yeah yeah uh you can't be
serious it's out and it's really fun
read it is really good um
and so thank you to cal for writing it
and for talking about it and thanks to
you for listening to him talk about it
the thing he wrote and we'll talk to you
next week
[Music]
the life is short is hosted by me justin
long and it's co-hosted and produced by
you friend of jerry o'connell's
christian law it's it's also produced by
megan v monaco and katie v allen also
friend to a lot of people another person
who has a lot of friends is the senior
producer michelle miesh lans
audio engineer is sergio enriquez and
the executive producer is marshall louie
for wondering
[Music]
i farted
[Music]
i think i spit on your shoes no no it's
not sorry
i'm practicing
and that means
that means i farted exactly or excuse me
i farted
to say that no you're not used to
you're not used to it you don't you
don't just call it out it's not even
no problems
you